asking ye shall receive
into the dalek if you saw my review of
deep breath wish was peter capaldi's
first episode
full episode at any rate as the new
doctor
well you may recall i said i was liking
what he was doing but he didn't
have me totally hooked into me and i was
waiting for you know those sort of
moments where i'm like
yeah that's the doctor well you know
what i got them pretty much
out of the gate on this episode the
pre-credit stuff just
the way he's interacting with the
characters that he's meeting for the
very first time and this
general dismissiveness he sort of has
and you can tell he's
he cares but the man's got no time for
niceties anymore
and i feel like in just a couple of
scenes i
got his doctor i buy into it i'm like
this
is the doctor this is i'm down with this
let's go
and it goes it goes very well i think
the moment
that it finally sold me on and out i
feel okay talking about this because
like i said i try to avoid spoilers but
this is
literally the first three minutes of the
episode but there's a woman a soldier
on the tardis pointing a gun at him
demanding that he
take her to her command carrier and he
keeps cutting her off and
telling her no and that she's saying it
wrong and he
keeps doing that until she asks politely
and says please
and then he takes her and he does it
with this so and this is not a game he's
being dead serious he's not playing
around it's not a test he
he's not going to do it till she asks
him nicely and
he sells that you know there's a cert
there's an arrogance there's a pomposity
to that
that really could have gone the wrong
way if you
had an actor that was pulling that kind
of stuff
but just didn't have the charisma that
peter capaldi has
it it wouldn't work but it works so i am
definitely down with a new guy how's the
episode
it's pretty darn good i love the daleks
naturally
and this is the daleks from a different
perspective
quite literally in fact but the doctor
and clara and a couple of soldiers they
get
physically trunking down and they go
inside a dalek
now as hokey and gimmicky as that sounds
it it
really does work because the reason that
they're going in is very compelling what
they're trying to accomplish once
they're there is really interesting
clara's working for me a little bit more
in this episode i still i still can't
get completely on board with her but
she's definitely working better for me
than she did last time because last time
she was all weird about
the doctor's regeneration even before he
was
showing the aspect of his new
personality which just didn't make any
sense to me given that she knew what
regeneration was
but now that she's seeing all these
sides of his personality and aspects to
him that she hadn't seen before that she
now has to cope with
now it makes a little bit more sense the
way that her interactions with him
are changing and how she's trying to
kind of deal with that
but she's also just rolling with it
better in general so it's a much better
balance than she had going on last time
around
we get the introduction of a character
called danny pink who it's been
mentioned
may serve as some sort of pseudo
additional companion it's it's been a
little vague maybe it's been made more
clear i try not to dig too much into
this stuff because i'd like to avoid
spoilers if i can
but i know he's going to be a recurring
character and we don't see him a ton but
i like him right off the bat he is fun
he's funny he's layered he's a soldier
which is really interesting because
the show has always taken pretty much
the doctor's perspective on soldiers and
the doctor does not have a great deal of
respect or
interest in soldiers he doesn't like
people who just follow orders and he
doesn't like people with a military
mentality and the show is pretty much
sided with him across the board on that
whenever soldiers or military characters
have shown up
and that's honestly even going way back
into the classic era so to have a
character as layered and as immediately
likeable as
danny pink is and having to be a soldier
offers a nice counterpoint to what we've
seen up to this point the daleks are
back in the daleks are always great fun
i am slightly disappointed because all
we see at this point are is the dalek
design that got introduced you know back
when
christopher eccleston took over which is
a great design don't get me wrong but
they now
seem to have completely abandoned the
new paradigm daleks which
bums me out because i liked them i found
them interesting and intriguing
we were usually seeing one or two
usually the supreme was still sort of
maintaining that
look like in asylum with the dialects
for example but
now it's just all we're seeing are these
ones that we've seen before and i was
kind of excited to see how their look
might change and evolve
kind of like the cybermen have but i i
guess we're not gonna get that
at least not now the only thing the
episode kind of has going against it is
the
aspects of the premise are kind of like
an amalgamation
of asylum of the daleks and let's kill
hitler because even though it wasn't as
literal as this we kind of got
inside of a dalek with asylum of the
daleks
and then there was the whole shrinking
down and going into a body with the test
elected now granted that was completely
a robot but they kind of recycled the
idea of
robotic antibodies and a few other
things feel like sort of reappropriated
ideas now they're good ideas they're
ones worth reusing but
just sort of the lack of any kind of
acknowledgement that they've kind of
done some of these things before i don't
know it makes me worried that the show's
becoming slightly less self-aware
but i don't know maybe i'm just reading
too much into that in any case this was
a great follow-up really strong capaldi
himself i think
better than he was last time not that he
was bad in deep breath but you could you
got the
feeling he was still getting his footing
i mean not so much like he didn't know
how to play him i'm sure
everything was completely calculated but
the character himself the doctor did
not know who he was yet and so therefore
neither do we as the audience
by now he knows who he is so that's it
for me on this one
what did you think about it and you know
what if you haven't caught this episode
yet or you know
even if you have put down in the
comments what is your favorite
dalek episode so far personally i gotta
go asylum of the daleks on that but
there are a lot of good ones out there
drop something down in the comments and
let's talk about it until next time
this council is adjourned